[Música]
boa tarde
meu nome é renan oliveira e hoje estou
aqui apresentar para vocês um possível
caminhão na educação e por que eu
resolvi hoje aqui no tek falar sobre o
possível caminho na educação poderiam
ser vários assuntos mas eu resolvi falar
aqui sobre a educação porque assim como
nelson mandela eu acredito que a
educação é uma das armas é a arma mais
poderosa que você quer um de vocês aí
pode usar para mudar o mundo
eu acredito no poder da educação e mais
do que acreditar no poder da educação eu
acredito que a educação pode transformar
vidas e se afirma miriam aérea que
coisas bonitas está falando isso eu vim
algum lugar de mas não somente houve
muitos lugares mas essa transformação
que eu tô falando eu vi acontecer na
prática na minha vida quando era menor
eu estou nessa escola aqui a escola frei
e essa escola é uma escola que ela quer
parceria com o educandário
para quem não sabe que a debandada do
contrário é um espaço que recebe
crianças carentes que os pais não têm
condições de cuidar das crianças durante
o dia tem condições de arrancar e com o
próprio nome já diz elas vão para o
educandário e eu pude estudar essa
escola que uma parceria com o
educandário a escola queria um lugar
para instalar essa parceria em troca do
calendário que as crianças do contrário
poderia estudar na escola de graça
isso foi muito bom pra mim como criança
porque naquela época não tinha
consciência do mundo isso me fez trazer
muita consciência consciência de que
existem outras classes sociais pessoas e
outras em outros momentos de vida que eu
não estava em outras realidades
eu tive a sorte de poder viver isso
porque eu ia para a escola o meu
principal objetivo era estudar eu ia
para a escola estudar os meus amigos
matriculados na escola alunos privados
também iam para lá estudar
mas quando olhava com um lado eu via que
tinham outros amigos meus que faziam
parte da opinião pública quando algo
mais feliz e eu querendo alguma coisa
além de estudar talvez ajudar você a
desculpa
muitos deles iam para lá a ter o que
vestir
muitos deles é um papel que comer porque
é o que eles iam comer naquele dia na
escola era uma refeição que eles não têm
no dia mas todos eles eu tenho certeza
absoluta que iam para lá buscando uma
forma melhor de viver modo a
oportunidade de mudar de vida e isso
quando eu paro para pensar nisso na
oportunidade de mudar de vida
eu reflito que talvez nem todos eles
tivessem a consciência que eles iam para
lá buscando isso às vezes vou para lá
para escapar de um ambiente em casa na
hora do gol para ter onde ficar
não tinha consciência mais buscando
mudar de vida
isso me faz lembrar o caso do amigo meu
uno eu estou comigo na escola foi nerd
fazia parte do calendário a família dele
não tinha tanta condição de cuidar dele
ele tinha história do canário e bruno
hoje eu fico muito feliz quando vejo as
fotos no facebook passando eu vejo a
publicação de bruno que tinha tudo pra
não conseguir vencer na vida
fardado quando em uma das empresas já
fazem outras empresas ou das maiores
empresas do rio grande do norte
eu vejo quando conferiu desde a mão do
filho dele o que o pai dele não
conseguiu dar pra ele e é por isso que
eu acredito no poder da educação e por
acreditar por educação eu resolvi me
dedicar aos meus esforços para trabalhar
com a educação para ser um educador e
hoje eu trabalho como ordenador de lã e
inspiração bonito pra dizer que a pessoa
que coordena que desenha toda jornada de
aprendizagem dos alunos em uma escola
online aqui pelo risco que tem como
principal objetivo transformar o
transformar a forma em que as pessoas
aprendem e educam olha a transformação
dessas pessoas aprendendo com isso é
você querer dar um possível caminho da
educação
e essa vontade de transformar se o mesmo
é porque as pessoas aprendem educam que
se conecta muito comigo porque se eu
olho pra trás
eu vejo na minha educação maior parte do
meio da semana foi chato eu estava lá
obrigado eu não gostava itália que a
tesão italy aprendendo ela foi passivo
os professores falavam de escutar
ela foi por obrigação e quando a coisa
por obrigação
você faz por obrigação você não tem
vontade de estar ali mas como diria
minha mãe
o mundo gira ea tapioca vira e hoje
hoje eu trabalho em uma escola que tem
como objetivo transformar a forma com
que as pessoas aprendem educam ou
parafraseando um dos fundadores da
escola de actores com murilo gun o nosso
principal objetivo é o propósito da
escolha o nosso principal objetivo é
como transformar a educação uma parada
massa paradas ativa de levantar do aluno
pra lá e por eu quero e quando falo no
lembre se que o aluno aprende se aquela
pessoa que aprende o anexo que aprendi
pode ser desde ser liberado na empresa
até o seu aluno dentro da sala de aula e
buscando resolver é da um possível
caminho o melhor mais do que o possível
caminho vários possíveis caminhos alguns
eu trouxe que alguns princípios que eu
acredito que vão fazer a educação se
transformar na parada massa e eu chamo
esse princípio dos cinco princípios da
onik se na experiência da jornada de
aprendizagem
já falei pra vocês o primeiro deles é o
sentido quando falam surgido primeira
palavra que vivem é sentido no sentido
de cultivo é sentido com significado do
motivo
quando eu falo no sentido significado de
última palavra que me vem a motivação
olharem pra falar vocês vão ver que essa
palavra pode ser dividido em duas partes
é o motivo ea ação
então quando você está ensinando ao para
alguém se você que ela quer que ela vá
pra ação que ela aprenda tem um motivo
de o porquê
desperta a motivação das pessoas através
de um motivo você quer que faça a
celebração aconteceu comigo isso minha
namorada dois anos atrás ela morava na
itália
eu fui visitá-la fazer uma visita rápida
e eu me peguei estudando a história do
coliseu aleatoriamente por quê porque eu
queria fazer da minha viagem com melhor
experiência possível e por isso fui
estudar a história toda a história do
coliseu a história da itália a história
do vaticano e por aí vai
mas porquê porque eu tenho um motivo que
me levou a se estudar eu queria fazer a
melhor experiência possível
e na escola e na os nossos aprendizes
porque a gente pode fazer como a gente
pode começar pelo motivo fica a reflexão
esse é só o primeiro pilar
segundo pilar o classificado foi o
significado me vêem uma teoria um
conceito deve aos meu que fala da
aprendizagem significativa aprendizagem
significativa acontece no momento em que
esse conteúdo qualquer conteúdo que
esteja passando eles se relacionam de
uma forma proposital como consta
conteúdo que vocês ou qualquer pessoa
que esteja aprendendo já sabe por
exemplo chegar aqui hoje no the next e
achar um lugar para estacionar foi como
achar uma agulha no palheiro
eu não preciso dizer que foi difícil
achar lugar para estacionar todo mundo
sabe que é um palheiro é muito grande
que uma agulha coisa por dinheiro eu
trouxe um significado vocês já conhecem
a embasar para tornar esse momento de
troca de conhecimento uma coisa que flui
melhor sabe fazer isso muito bem
empreendedores pessoas que têm negócio
quando vou explicar porque é seu negócio
meu negócio é um google o mundo do
direito não precisa dizer que o negócio
é um negócio é um plataforma online de
pesquisa para buscar conteúdos do mundo
jurídico a quantidade de palavras eu
falei se eu falar que é um do mundo do
direito
vocês entenderam isso e aprendizagem
significativa e isso favorece toda a
jornada de lurex de aprendizagem
exemplar encantamento encantar é quase
que fundamental no mundo de hoje como a
gente já viu aqui é alguns
ontem algumas palestras eu queria
começar falando de si lá você não
pergunta por que é tão legal a gente
assistir um filme é tão chato a gente
aciona uma aula porque no fim de duas
horas instalar a ave dado tapas no filme
avatar no banheiro se pagam para entrar
e não vou agora não vou assistir até o
final mas na hora da sala de aula da 15
minutos está ali 15 minutos só libera
está conversando com colegas um lado
porque existem vários motivos eu queria
trazer alguns aqui pra vocês porque eu
teria que reverter esses motivos é uma
forma de cantar
um deles é o tal do storytelling é
contar uma história
hoje toda a história para alguém a gente
parte de um lugar com um dos personagens
de a medida surge o desafio e vai
crescendo vai crescer vai crescer vai
crescendo aquele desafio daqui a pouco o
clima ele se resolve deixar mensagem
em resumo pode contratar sim se a gente
fizer isso dentro dos conteúdos hoyama
os conteúdos que a gente tem para
entregar os novos aprendizes para trazer
ele para o jogo a gente usar um morro a
ferramenta simples coisas bestas
talvez ficasse mijando qualquer coisa
são ferramentas beijos que a gente pode
utilizar muito simples que fazem
diferença gatilhos do marketing da
persuasão para gerar curiosidade o meu
público
tudo isso faz parte do encantamento ir
pro quarto pilar o nosso quarto pilar é
o pilar experiência
a experiência é o que rodeia todo o seu
conteúdo e pra falar da experiência eu
queria também trazer um caso clássico
que acontece algumas vezes imagina que a
gente tá no bairro não pode tomar agora
vão assistir à palestra mas que imagina
que a gente tá no bairro de você veja
cerveja veio em campo gelado
pedimos um petisco ele veio delicioso
mas na hora que você começa a pedir o
gasto depois chegou a cerveja e petiscos
funcionou bem na hora que você perde a
conta com tv e rádio cobrando uma coisa
que você não pediu a retomada das obras
não está errado quem não se vira
por mais deliciosa tinha sido comida por
mais gelado tem sido a cerveja a sua
experiência vai ficar comprometida então
aprendizagem acontece a mesma coisa se
ajeitem o conteúdo e fez um lindo mas o
em couro do conteúdo em torno do
conteúdo a experiência não favorece o
que acontece
a experiência ficar completa a gente
prejudicar a nossa jornada de
aprendizagem e aí vem o desafio vem a
pergunta como promover uma experiência
memorável experiência que gera memórias
eu também trago aqui alguns possíveis
caminhos pra vocês
o primeiro deles que tal ensinar através
de pequenos jogos
aquele sino que as pessoas não sentem
que estão aprendendo que tal se a gente
vai ensinar alguma coisa que precisa
levar o aprendiz pra um ambiente um
ambiente diferente que está inserido
usar realidade virtual pra levar essa
pessoa a esse ambiente crianças podem
ver dinossauros já tem um museu fazendo
isso através da realidade virtual
que tal seguindo esse conceito passado
vários slides mas volta que tal seguindo
esse conceito a gente mudar o nosso
material físico pra não ser só conteúdo
folha de papel preço é algo que
realmente atrai a que tal se vocês acham
como eu falei que ficava na sala de aula
ambientes grava tem que pensar em
alcançar essa pessoa da platéia nesse
meio tempo a semana
você pode fazer a diferença é que você
pode prova mais leve por exemplo
investir na financeira
todos esses conceitos são consenso
você vai aprender próximo tem mistério
digitais e embora a teoria de piro
mas hoje a nossa do conteúdo das pessoas
que você confie que novo impressionou
nesta jornada que talvez compreender
juntos e bastante jornada ensinar
pensando que talvez você precise na
grande final
são cinco pilares sentir vocês viram um
momento importante em que diferentes
não é só o alerta chega para falar do
novo marcel que estava perdendo você mas
você pode ensinar o que a senhora quer
uma coisa vai fazer saber ele sabe fazer
uma primeira aprovação da mensagem final
minutos que consegui passar para vocês
nos princípios além do hospital
inscrição e você professor que você da
boca vira empresa que 'ensina' outras
pessoas quando você pode fazer
utilizando ferramentas que eu tenho um
convite para fazer todos juntos pela
educação tomada mas
[Aplausos]
[Música]